Richard mm-hmm I think I heard something  stay here  oh what a hearty lunch he's a wanted  felon you're an upstanding citizen  sometimes a good guy wins what's this  that's not the guy I shot it's called  shock I should go home and let me deal  with the police for thing here you got  you on that snack it's not something on  friday police want a statement from me  it's all over the school so what happens  now Weber the sin of a [ __ ] he got any  family daddy in Huntsville prison just  got paroled mr. Russell I'm sorry yea  dein right your boy he looks a whole lot  like you done d  he's in a house get back in the car my  god  it's probably just ran scary  don't let him  okay don't you worry that is not the guy  what are we supposed to do now Luke  detective agency before do you won't  take this cops are up to something they  use my family as bait I want to know why  alright boys how they do tea time